ban
le tribunal judiciaire de versailles a
fonctionné autant qu'il pouvait pendant
ces semaines de confinement sur le plan
juridictionnel pénale aux termes
d'audiences correctionnelles la
juridiction fonctionner à peu près à 50
% de sa capacité
ce que le parquet et la juridiction
pénale a été amené à traiter trait
essentiellement ce sont les infractions
au confinement sous leur forme
délictuelle bien entendu puisque en
matière contraventionnelle la
juridiction n'avait pas en connaître
c'est sous forme de procès verbal
électronique
nous avons traité aussi et c'est en
train de monter progressivement pour
reprendre la tête je dirais les
violences intrafamiliales que ce soit
des violences au sein du couple que ce
soit parfois des violences sur les
enfants ou sur les ascendants d'ailleurs
nous avons été amenés à 1,6 à traiter un
certain nombre d'infractions liées on va
dire globalement tendu à ce qu'on
appelle les violences urbaines avec une
gravité relative
heureusement même si on a eu à déplorer
un cas tout à fait dramatique d'une
petite fille de cinq ans qui a été
atteinte par un tir lors d'une d'un
échange d'une altercation entre à
chanteloup les vignes entre les forces
de l'ordre
et puis les personnes qui les
attaquaient
cette période nous a conduits à a poussé
à son maximum
quelque chose qui à mon avis est une
qualité intrinsèque du magistrat
peut-être encore plus du parquetier qui
est le sens de l'adaptation de la
décision rapide et de l'adaptation une
juridiction
c'est une dyarchie donc je suis seul à
vous parler mais j'ai travaillé avec le
président de cette juridiction élu avec
moi et avec l'ensemble du personnel
dirigeant de greffe et ça nous enseigne
de manière encore plus certaine que la
collectivité bien plus intelligente et
bien plus efficace quand elle fonctionne
effectivement de cette manière là on
s'est fait un petit peu malmené les
juridictions par des articles de presse
qui rapportait des propos notamment de
membres de certains barreaux comme quoi
la justice elle était planqué les
magistrats étaient planqués
heureusement que les greffes était là et
encore eux aussi se faisait vilipendé
mais en gros personne ne faisait rien et
tout le monde était caché ça c'est
inadmissible et ça n'est pas la réalité
la juridiction versaillaise au premier
chef puisque c'est celle que je veux
mettre en valeur elle s'est adaptée n a
pas à rougir de son bilan
c'est un des confinement qui va prendre
en compte pour l'organisation et la vie
du tribunal à partir de lundi de données
très essentiel en fait que sont d'une
part l'absolue nécessité de respecter
les règles de distanciation sociale et
gestes barrières qui s'applique à nous
et à ce public que nous n'avions plus
jusqu'à présent mais qui va revenir dans
la juridiction donc physiquement nous
allons installer des barrières
nous allons donner des masques à ceux
qui n'en auront pas mais nous demandons
à ce que par exemple les personnes qui
viennent au tribunal soit muni d'un
masque et seules les personnes munies
d'un masque pourront rentrer vous avez
par exemple un certain nombre
d'audiences qui sont des audiences de
cabinet par exemple les juges aux
affaires familiales
les juges des enfants les délégués du
procureur et à tout un tas de
fonctionnement au sein de la juridiction
où les règles de distanciation sociale
ne pourront plus être respectée sur les
anciennes manières de fonctionner donc
il faut qu'on utilise de manière
différente
l'espace dont on dispose la deuxième
contrainte qui s'impose à nous ses
vis-à-vis des effectifs phase est celle
qui est relative aux effectifs dont nous
disposons tant du côté des magistrats
que du côté des fonctionnaires cette
communauté de travail là elle est comme
les gens de l'extérieur soumises à des
difficultés éventuelles ou transport des
difficultés de garde d'enfants des
problèmes de maladies des problèmes et
c'est donc nous mêmes nous allons
adapter notre activité aux effectifs
dont nous disposons